hot breath how to sound more
conversational
in delivering material that's a great
that's a great question because
and one thing i emphasize with people in
my workshops is that comedy is a
conversation
right and so we we forget that comedy is
a conversation
it's mostly one-sided but when you're
talking
you see your audience doing a lot of
this they acknowledge they heard or
processed the
the setup and that's where your timing
comes from is listening to them making
sure they're listening to you
they heard what you had to say they kind
of responded with a little oh yeah okay
yeah yeah i saw that and then you
punched the punch line
with it or whatever but that is a
conversation
one way to do it is to trick yourself
like um
johnny carson used to do this
um did you guys see this
i read this in the paper in minnesota
it's a conversation now
that's questions you got you guys see
this um jay leno hey
um maybe uh did did you notice this in
the news today
that sort of thing right and so jimmy
fallon does the same thing
so you're actually forcing yourself oh
[ __ ] before i forget
i got to tell you guys these
these are little kind of things to make
sure you kind of trick your brain
and because we've got this image ever
since we were little of what a
performance is
and so when we take that stage that's
still with us
rather than getting up there and going
you know holy [ __ ] i haven't seen you
guys in a while
you never met them in your life you know
they're going to laugh at that idea
and you know uh but that's why it
corporates
i'll always go sit down at the first
table that's you know downstage left
and have have uh the dinner with them or
whatever and then
ask them their names and play a little
little name game with them and
talk to them about you know their time
at the company so that way when i'm up
on stage
i can always go to my friends and call
them by name and the audience thinks oh
he knows these people oh he's one of us
right away so they feel engaged with
you and that's a great question because
we talk about this with how people love
this community
comedy clubs that's why people come to
the shows they don't know it
because they love that to feel that
sense of community the moment you bring
them in
and give them a purpose that's part of
the show
magic that's could make the difference
of the entire show
uh um taylor tomlinson does this thing
which i i saw her on one of her her last
special i think it was
and it was brilliant she comes in the
audience is cheering
in her intro and she's touched
by the level of enthusiasm from this
audience and she goes
and you could actually hear them they
pick it up
and she goes boy i can't wait till my ex
sees this that
line right there said you're on my side
we're gonna prove it to that [ __ ]
and they're like yeah we got you we got
your back we're gonna we're gonna prove
it to them too
so you've now working their superior
they feel that superiority
we're gonna get him yeah you know and
they're right on board with you and she
just in that little line brought them
right into this community
it is a conversation right now yeah it's
interesting like
so you may have a one-liner that's very
rigid and structured but it's like
have a little runway into that one-liner
to make it a little more conversational
so instead of like
having a setup punch about your wife
it's just kind of like so i've been
married for three years and here's the
setup punch about my wife like almost
just a little
runway up to the punch line can make it
more conversational
and this is a great time to use crowd
work organically right i said you know
i've been married my wife for about 15
years how many people married you
married you married yeah what's your
name you know
bill uh okay bill uh how long you've
been married uh six years uh one more
and it's over right
uh then you have now you're building in
jokes to the conversation because seven
you're rich
and then you say but every name you have
and information you have from that
person how long you've been married oh
15 years hey you and i we're on the same
page right
miserable uh so uh we say and i'll get a
female's perspective because it's always
good to have the female perspective
because i'm a man
i love to look at you know that's why i
bought cosmo i subscribed to cosmo when
it was in high school
because i wanted the other team's
playbook i wanted to hear other point
that other point of view that i'm not
privy to
so that opens so it's like when in the
in the classroom or
on stage when i when i include a female
i hear her perspective
and i'll ask them you know and now each
one of those gives me a joke opportunity
on top of that now i have fodder to call
back to
right do you have any kids yeah three
kids so i'll go through and somebody
else has you know how many kids you got
three three oh well we should talk to
tim over here he's got three kids you
guys should get together and [ __ ] you'll
be the brady bunch
right and then next thing you know we
get everybody's laughing because you're
making this [ __ ] up as you go
and uh being crass about it sometimes
just for
and frivolous and now you can go into
your material
you know so i've been married 15 years
let me tell you now the one liner or one
and two liner
right and you build off of that but now
you have a conversation sometimes the
crowd work can be so minimal
one of my students she showed she did
she did a
a set got a great response and she did
the
the set again another night and she goes
it didn't go as well
i did the exact same set i said i bet
you you didn't do the exact same set
and she goes i bet you i did i said okay
what's the bet coffee
good all right so i said bring in the
videos do you have them she goes yeah
she brings them in
so the first she did virtually the same
set the same material but in that first
set they got the big response
she goes hi y'all that's how she opens
and it's in l.a so people are little oh
wait y'all oh
that's quirky giggle giggle right just a
little giggle
and this one guy kind of made a snort or
something and she goes
i love the way you laugh with this big
smile
and that made them laugh more community
immediately community oh my god i love
the way you live
i'm taking you with me on the road
communion where
you just brought him right in man and
then i said
that's what got him you had a
conversation you were not in your head
reciting material
it doesn't take a lot just takes a
little bit of not afraid to look at look
at them in the eyes and
engage with them